台灣股市今天
MSCI大甩尾
台灣股市今天只跌200多點而已
今天很多人以為欣興的事件
讓台灣股市要跌1000多點
沒有
可是欣興事件會不會影響
你看今天股票跌停板
環球晶還有誰
還有國巨 還有被動元件
可是為什麼有些股票尾盤拉起來
我今天要一次講個夠 來啦
台股今天尾盤爆量急拉
明天穩了
第二個 明天9月了
第二個 8月大漲3008點
9月要漲更多嗎
第三個 欣興被調查
這些投信認養股 其他的股票
國巨 環球晶這些通通都慘了嗎
所有的飆股介紹
還有所有的弱勢股
我能講的我一次今天講個夠
台股今天比較震盪
一度大跌快900點
最後只跌了202點
收跌在46128點
今天台股大跌
但是投資長的股票
居然還逆勢大噴出
投資長的好戲登場
精材這檔股票創下歷史新高
大漲接近漲停
真的太強啦
開心之餘 投資朋友們一定也很好奇
國巨和環球晶
今天怎麼會打到跌停
難道大跌跟Fed主席華許
在央行年會釋出的偏鷹訊號有關聯嗎
還是一切都是今天
打入跌停涉及洗產地的欣興惹的禍
接下來就交給我們
經濟日報選股冠軍
單季188%的紀錄保持者
同時也是全台灣唯一百萬粉絲
最受歡迎的分析師
郭哲榮投資長 投資長好
Lily 各位投資朋友大家好
今天台股好刺激
我有精材漲停板
但是我跟你講
我等一下偏偏先講國巨
你看國巨拉起來 華新科拉起來
華新科最後只有跌5%
你看你不趁跌的時候買
什麼時候買
各位投資朋友
不趁這個時候買 什麼時候買
我跟你講 不離不棄是我兄弟
我今天在Threads寫
我現在每一則Threads
都1 200萬人看 是
我說過買進國巨 悲喜加劇
上禮拜漲停 這禮拜跌停
不是漲停就是跌停
人家不是漲就是跌
他是不是漲停就是跌停
但是哲哲說過
命一條 衝就對了
反正國巨有1200元的人幫我們墊背
我知道有些人很難過
但是墊背的你可以拉低平均
把平均價格拉低 是不是
1200再買個500多元
是不是 你的平均成本就不到900元
800多元就可以解套了
你要開心啦
今天的國巨會拉起來
一切怎麼樣
一切都是月亮惹的禍是不是
唱一下這個月亮惹的禍
我承認都是月亮惹的禍
繼續唱啊 查一下
而且要改版
不是月亮惹的禍
星星 月亮 太陽是誰惹的禍
欣興
一切都是欣興惹的禍
洗產地啦
我跟你講
最晚明後天一定會打開啦
不要想太多 好不好
ABF載板 我都不懂
去年我70幾塊的時候
被人家罵得要死
現在1000多塊跌停板
還是999 是真的啊
可是這也是我告訴大家
我有沒有說 我說你看喔
我算一下00981A
如果到上禮拜五
大概我買台灣50
你同時去買00981A
你大概賺30%
這麼多
可是也是00981A
主動型ETF最大的問題
他們會去追強勢股 是
就是我不會去買這麼貴的股票
他已經70塊了
我1000多塊還持有他幹什麼
你懂嗎 懂
這就是這一波
為什麼國巨我沒有受傷
我沒有要去怪主動型ETF
我不是要去噹00981A
我講的是事實
這就是我說的
我說等到台灣股市
48000的時候怎麼樣
你賺90%對不對
你再去換什麼
00981A再換什麼
0050啊 我對你們很好耶
投資朋友
等到32塊的時候再換0050
台股要創新高的時候換0050
為什麼 因為0050最抗跌
不要說最抗跌
相對於主動型ETF
相對於大部分的主動型ETF
相對很抗跌
現在網路上在給你討論
高股息ETF 00878 00什麼的
全部到最後這幾年怎樣
大家講0056
我這幾年從頭到尾
我就跟你講說0056比較好
你們每次看到什麼00878
看到新的ETF有沒有
還有什麼00940
什麼台灣高息是不是
忘記了 是
這都是什麼高股息
我說OK
我就說就買0056就好了
可是0056再怎麼樣也不會贏0050
我從頭到尾講這些
我有因為這樣收到會員嗎
沒有 我不會因為這樣收到會員的啦
大家只會對我頂多有好感
但是我人在做天在看
我希望能矯正各位錯誤的投資觀念
因為我觀眾太多了
1 200萬粉絲
要有正確的投資觀念
能幫一個是幫一個
你看看今天什麼趙建銘也好
什麼陳幸妤也好
講到0050都可以翻個2倍 3倍了
就是這樣子
所以台灣股市現在只是欣興惹的禍
來 我們來唱一下
來 欣興惹的禍
欣興造成環球晶 國巨跌
為什麼
先唱一下 來
我承認都是欣興惹的禍
那樣洗產地股價太恐怖
台語喔
洗產地太恐怖
人家洗產地 我告訴你
來看一下 作圖給你看
我跟你講
很多人拿什麼被檢調調查
那不是重點
是洗產地 有沒有看到
美超微高層也是遭起訴
非法走私AI晶片洗產地
他們更誇張 有影片喔
怎麼樣 把那個標籤撕下來再貼
用吹風機吹
吹風機成犯罪工具
大家有沒有印象 有
是今年3月的事情而已 是
19.48 因為他有拆股
19.48漲到51.4
到今天也是兩倍
所以我跟你講基本面還是王道
我跟你講
1000多元的欣興我沒有很喜歡
但是我認為明天就會打開了
再講一次
1000多元的欣興我沒有很喜歡
但是我認為明天就會打開了
明天
打開有兩種做法
第一個 你明天當日沖
我沒有建議
我從頭到尾沒有建議你當沖
好不好 你不要問我要不要沖
我知道有些人是這樣子
第二個 你也可以買誰比較多
譬如00981A或者主動型ETF
明天開盤買他會拉起來一點點
但是那個影響很低
可能只漲1 2%而已
你懂不懂 是
所以你明天要進場是開盤就買
OK嗎 這個我跟大家講
除非他明天一開盤就上漲 好不好
明天就打開 我再給你預告
我就是敢預告
那因為他 很多人就說
可能賣了一些主動型ETF
或主動型ETF怕連環殺 是
你懂不懂
連環殺的一個火燒連環船
我一定要賣一些股票
可能有些大家想像
或者有些主動型ETF
或有些ETF
我把投信認養的股票也先砍一砍
我砍不了欣興嘛
就像那時候為什麼流動性風險
有沒有 那時候不是什麼
我一直在跟他
希望主管機關有沒有 有
拜託一下
把那處置股改一下 有沒有
現在變成好像是多少
2分鐘交易一次嘛
那時候是20分鐘交易一次
是 差很多
流動性風險
我賣不掉這個跌停板的處置的股票
20分鐘交易一次
我只能賣活的
沒有被處置的股票
變成台灣股市
有沒有看到說一直有點無量下跌
量很少下跌
你看一改變制度後就拉起來了
所以現在欣興跌停板
會有人怕
會有人想像力說
會不會影響到別的股票
所以有些投信認養的高價股
又是AI的概念股
就被殺了
就這麼無聊的事情啊
那就買啊
老天爺送錢給你為什麼不買
我告訴大家 澄清一下
我沒有買1000元的國巨
以上也沒有 今年沒有
900元以上也沒有
800元以上也沒有
700元以上也沒有
600元我印象中也沒有 好不好
我們是買4 500元的
這個跟大家講 好不好
來 所以這都是一樣啊
所以趕快買
有些網紅可能是問AI啦
台灣被檢調調查的股票怎麼樣
問AI有什麼用
因為他問的問法不一樣嘛 是
你知道我看有些網紅這樣講
他說我跟你講 我做個表格
那都是AI做的 一看就知道
為什麼 就沒有認真啊
因為他問的問法有問題啊
被檢調調查過後
股價怎麼漲 怎麼跌
他們每個東西
被檢調調查的不一樣 是
你懂嗎 如果你說全公司
上下都在做這件事
那就有問題嘛
可不是嘛 人家副總嘛
而且他還說什麼
他說這不是PCB
這不是ABF載板
他還了解股票要做什麼
有沒有 澄清爭議產品非載板
有沒有看到
因為現在載板的
已經營收比重已經
逐漸要超過五成了
你知道嗎 是
他知道大家想聽什麼 你知道嗎
他說爭議產品是什麼
爭議產品有沒有看到
是PCB產品 不是載板
不是高階ABF載板
跟AI沒有關係啦
那當然硬要說PCB也有啦
但是這是很
這個是2 30年前產品了啦 好不好
3 40年前產品了啦 PCB
高階產品跟AI更有關係啦
可是高階產品不是調查範圍
是低階產品啊
有沒有看到 給你澄清有沒有看到
第二個有沒有 還有什麼
產地標示爭議 沒關係
至少不是作假帳
只要這家公司不是作假帳
就是營收不是假的
都有機會處理 再講一次
會不會被美國處置 處置不完啦
多少有做些東西 好不好
這個跟大家講
所以我覺得
第一個被美國營收影響 不重要
你與其關心這個
你不如關心AI可不可以變現
AI有沒有營收兌現出來
當然有啊
投資朋友來看一下
來 所以跟你講
我那時候不是有講一件事
我說禮拜一有機會跌 對
而且有機會大跌至少5%以上
而且我還說一件事情
我說過如果是影響營收 那不一樣
如果今天是營收造假 作假帳
這不算作假帳 這是洗產地
什麼是作假帳
就是營收是假的
我100億的營收裡面20億是假的
那慘了
那這家公司誠信有問題
可能不止20億
那個公司3根跌停板
我都勸你不要買
明天欣興有機會打開
但我不會買
我不會買為什麼
他強任他強 清風拂山崗
因為我有社會責任 投資朋友
我郭哲榮現在到這個程度
我少賺一點沒關係
我要求的是會員不要多賠
我不敢說我每次都一定賺
我不是這種 有賺有賠
你想要看到每天賺的
拜託你去找詐騙集團 不要找我
還有老投顧
每天跟你講賺錢的
你就知道死定了
你就知道什麼叫做詐騙
不要講別的同業這樣
你就知道什麼叫胡扯
還有另外一種詐騙集團才會天天賺
我沒辦法
可是我至少可以控制風險
欣興我不管他
我管他漲到2000塊 漲到3000塊
莫名其妙 70塊的時候
你們每個人罵我罵得要命
我都不懂為什麼那時候不珍惜呢
就像國巨一樣
搞不好像國巨是我的
我講的是1200是我的
跟我沒關係
我是英雄救美
我說1200墊背
你們聽了也不要難過
至少我有幫你們也來墊背一下
只是每個人墊背的角度不同 懂嗎
來 所以我要告訴大家
你看AI會不會變現
當然會啊 你看今天
MIT警告有沒有看到
MIT是誰
不是美國在台協會 是麻省理工
Lily在美國讀書就知道
麻省理工很難唸吧 是
數一數二天才能去那邊有沒有
他怎麼說 校長怎麼說
校長說AI已經完成大部分作業了
他說現在已經不需要學校
他類似這樣子
校園文化劇烈改變
讀書會 教授諮詢受到影響
現在不用讀書會了
不用教授諮詢了
大家沒有互動了
連麻省理工都這樣講
我有沒有跟你講
你知道嗎 是
其實我跟你講一件事
我真的希望你們看到我看到的未來
我不要講是誰
之前有一個人面試
他離開了
我也沒有要針對他
所以我也不希望那個人對號入座
其實我那時候很難過
因為那時候他去上一上以後
他發現可能我們這邊壓力比較大
他面試的時候
他本來要當儲備分析師
來沒幾天以後
他還是要回去當補教業者
我就跟他說孩子啊
我沒有講孩子 他不是這種
就是我跟他講
那時候我跟他講一件事
因為他那時候不懂AI
我說AI已經能取代你了
我叫你解任何題目
你解的都沒有邏輯比他好
我邏輯算很強的
這個就像下象棋一樣
下五子棋一樣 下圍棋一樣
AI就是想得比你多 比你恐怖
所以你解任何題目的時候
所有的邏輯他都解得很清楚
而且不到1秒鐘
不到30秒全部都解完了
老師光是要抄黑板
就可能要5分鐘 對
你根本不用補習
基本上現在只要智商中上
甚至中等以上的人
你只要會用AI
接下來你都不用去補習班
你只要買教材就好了
我有沒有講過這句話 有
我也跟那個人講說
其實就算你不喜歡這份工作
我們這份工作
你也不要去補教業者
我是跟大家講
你現在各位 你是補教業者
你要去想的是出路
我不能說補教業者全部都會被毀滅
但是他可能最大的功用就是照顧小孩
讓小孩子或讓國中生 高中生
有一個地方去而已
現在真的不需要了
MIT都說了
校園文化劇烈轉變
我有沒有早就跟你講
你現在連MIT都承認了
教授諮詢受到影響
不用了 因為你們這些教授
沒有辦法 我不是瞧不起
是教授真的 AI都比教授強
任何一個
不要說任何一個
這樣講很侮辱人
比99.9%的教授都強
你們要相信我看到的未來
我是不是在第一天的時候就這樣講 是
導播我是不是第一天就這樣講 對
所以我告訴你台灣股市10萬點很正常
你們要相信我看到的未來
只是什麼時候
When How
我不會跟你很肯定說一定什麼時候
什麼這樣子的
因為我是合格分析師
MIT就跟你講
所以重點是AI行不行
不要每天看那些數字
或看華爾街的數字
或看外資分析的數字
那沒有用 他們沒有想像力
我跟你講
你們不論是補教業者
尤其是 我再講喔
尤其是客服
你們也不要說什麼現在AI客服
現在的AI客服
跟隨便一個ChatGPT
衍生出來自己可以製造的AI客服
差太多了
我跟你講再過2到3年內
甚至2年內 1年內
很多的客服就會失業
你們要記得我這句話
很多客服 很多的駕駛
很多的行業 法律助理
很多行業會被取代
你們要有危機感
同時要從危機感裡面賺到錢
這是我郭哲榮看到的未來
MIT直接告訴你了
認知放棄了
我不用學了啦 反正我用AI也不行
以後最厲害的是會問問題的人
哲哲很會問問題
你不懂沒關係 每天看我的節目
好不好 你會發現
我看到的未來是很恐怖的
然後這10年把身體養好
比較老年的 40歲以上的
把身體養好
因為以後有
現在得癌症
跟10年後得癌症差很多
現在得癌症可能沒藥醫
10年後得癌症可能大部分癌症都有救
可是還是要強調把身體養好
你身體一直不養好也沒辦法
三高要用好
膽固醇有比較高的人一定要吃藥
這是未來的趨勢好不好
要把他當作跟善存一樣
我都跟你預告了
講實在話 你健不健康關我什麼事
沒有 這就是我的任務
我希望大家開開心心賺到錢
所以講AI這個東西
欣興明天就會打開
我不敢說一定啦
因為我沒有要碰它
我只能說機率很高啦
好不好 今天尾盤還是很多股票拉起來
MSCI生效嘛
台積電 聯電還好
來 聯電也拉了
一堆股票拉起來了
助理沒給我寫聯電 我自己發現到
廣達也拉起來了
哲哲台股有救了
沒有 這個純粹是MSCI生效
2330台積電也拉起來了
你看0050尾盤還沒拉
明天就有機會拉了
是不是 也是賺1000多萬
所以跌的時候你會發現到
0050會比00981A好
可是這接下來是00981A會彈比較快
跌它會跌比較多 彈它會彈比較快
彈它會彈比較快 反彈會比較快
記得我這些邏輯好不好
哲哲是為大家好啊
真的 我希望你不要把我當分析師
把我當預言家
你久了就知道
真的有些錢我不屑賺
我為了大家好 來
真的謝謝你讓我賺到錢
不能說一定 因為我是合格分析師
我真的是 對啊 來
456更甜 問題是456來了還敢買嗎
差不多就可以買了啦 好不好
來 複習1要會剪指甲
不管是國巨紅燈還是綠燈
All in了啦
群聯要噴了嗎 來
00981A買很多欣興
覺得說欣興會影響到跌的股票
我跟你講 這就是分散投資買ETF
就是永遠我都會跟你講
你再問我100次
我還是會告訴你買0050勝過台積電
為什麼
因為我是先求不傷身再求療效
台積電不知道什麼時候不行
我認為很大機率
2 30年內它還是很OK 是
可是萬一不行怎麼辦
所以買台灣50
畢竟大部分是台積電
但不是所有是台積電
記得這件事
買台灣50畢竟大部分是台積電
但不是所有是台積電
當台積電不行的時候
還是有分散風險的能力
所以0050在我心中
還是永遠大於台積電
你不能事後跟我講台積電績效比較好
去反駁我的理論
我是從風險來跟你講
OK嗎 看你要什麼樣的
你要台積電很好
或是以後看
那不對 你沒有分散投資的風險
這就是為什麼我說
我還沒講完
為什麼沒有分散投資的風險
你說00981A
那時候買很多 買什麼幾萬張欣興
00981A你管他幾萬張
他市值3000億
規模有3000億 是
你管他買幾萬張
他7%而已
他大概買差不多220億 很多
220億佔他的7%很多嗎
一根跌停板多少
一根跌停板影響不到1%
你自己不會算嗎
7.5%嘛
一個跌停板不是跌10%嗎
7.5%再乘上0.1
不就是0.75% 是的
7.5% 200多億看起來很多
所以我就說嘛
你們有時候有些人奇怪的數字
所以有些人真的數字不是很好
我不能怪你們
不是每個人像我數學那麼好的
或是有些人數學好
他會執著在某一個點 那都不對
欣興影響 頂多一根跌停板
頂多0.75% 這就是分散投資
你管他買200多億
人家規模那麼大可以嗎
他們都規定不會買那麼多
你懂我的意思嗎
所以我告訴你
這就是買ETF的好處
比你買個股好多了
所以台灣50在我心目中
就是比什麼
就是比只買台積電好
你這個東西可能2 30年後
你才覺得我是對的
沒關係 我會活到那個時候
好不好 OK
你可以不信行情
但是你要相信哲哲一定有剪指甲
對 我在Threads上面講一些幹話
來啦 我們跟大家講一件事
我們一樣
為什麼說有剪指甲的笑話
不是說那個 有一個故事嗎
就是中國的女明星景甜
是不是 跟一個男生交往
那個孫什麼 孫宇晨是不是
那個人真的很過分
我說真的很過分
我很少說混蛋兩個字
但我覺得他就是
男人 拜託 拿得起放得下
你給人家錢又給他要回來
你嘴巴講一講
要回來就算了
還鉅細靡遺講他們兩個發生什麼關係
還說AI不給錢的
我跟你講
結果他所有的前任都說他小氣鬼
難看死了 你不覺得
不論是陳幸妤的事件也好
或Joeman的事情
說穿了都是錢的事情
所以錢不要計較
跟對方不要計較
你讓人家女生或誰
錢委屈了 身體委屈了
心委屈了 錢也委屈了
當然人家會覺得你過分
景甜沒講什麼話
但是現在每個人都討厭這個男生
你多有錢 身價2000多億
在我眼裡看起來
比身價不到1000萬的還小氣
那沒有意義
重點是還說
我要摸他的胸部
還說那個女明星嫌他沒有剪指甲
是不是
還說嫌他沒有剪指甲
然後還幫他磨指甲磨了1小時
我說沒關係
我再次
我的節目有三大保證 看一下
第一個大保證
我絕對會剪指甲
第二大保證
絕對不跟前任要回1億
你要1億 我們來教你投資
用1億來賺個2000萬 3000萬
賺個1億是不是更好 是
這樣人生不會只有失憶
剩下是滿滿的回憶
而且絕對不爆對方料
只爆飆股料
我絕對會剪指甲 來看一下
等一下 我指甲長出來了
這一根長出來了
我指甲為什麼長出來了
長太快了
怎麼辦 這樣子我的節目還有三大保證
你不能怪我 我真的有剪指甲
我禮拜五到現在有剪指甲
導播來 拿個指甲刀我來一下
你來幹嘛
我可以幫你磨指甲1個小時
甚至可以凌晨4點煮牛肉麵
下麵給你吃
你不要啦 你走開 謝謝
是剪指甲 不是甲
有人說我甲鬼甲怪
指甲啦
沒關係 不論是同性 女性
大家我都喜歡
但是千萬導播
你就是不能靠近我
你知道他每次都這樣子
都會幫我用個褲管還怎麼樣
什麼叫凌晨4點
煮牛肉麵下麵給我吃
拜託 你這個節目性騷擾
好不好 我真的不舒服
好啦 給大家開玩笑的
我指甲長比較快
所以你看真的是體態管理都很重要
不過我告訴大家
小氣就小氣 不要怪AI好不好
他還怪AI
還說AI叫他不要出錢
我跟你講 我大膽預測
他接下來事業會有災難 你知道嗎
災難嗎 會有災難
因為其實我跟你講
你們最傻的就是買什麼虛擬貨幣
都是被人家
他只是運氣好
他發行那個貨幣以後
不到一個月中國就禁止了
不然他哪能賺到錢
他有能力啦
但是他把所有人都利用光光了
沒有人會相信他
我身邊的人
去打聽哲哲的為人
我說話算話
該給多少就給多少
我做交易都是
Win win situation
不會只有我郭哲榮賺
也要讓對方賺
只有我賺 對方不賺的生意我不做
我就算拗你我也講得很清楚
我這個人就是這樣子
人在做天在看
我也講清楚
我說如果對方一定要搞我
同業要搞我
不好意思 我花幾百萬 幾千萬
我都要耗下去
花一年 十年
你敢跟我耗也沒關係
結果呢
一個張分析師
我也覺得很難過啊
有必要為了這件事情
搞到視網膜剝離
他一定很生氣嘛
搞到心血管阻塞了嗎
你有必要嗎
沒有必要嘛
你要耗 是不是
他還有新聞
那個新聞到底是怎樣
是他去採訪還是怎樣
還是什麼事情
還是花錢的嗎 我不知道
可是我可以確定一件事情
然後呢 如果他最後輸呢
怎麼辦
那就算他贏了 身體也不好
算了 我不要講
人在做天在看
我不敢說我是道德魔人
一定都脾氣很好
一定都不會亂罵人
一定不會闖黃燈什麼
可是我投資道德
你絕對可以高規格要求我 OK
這個跟大家講 來
導播不能去游泳
因為鉀碰到水會爆炸
我也要幫哲哲剪指甲
要磨好不然會流血
這節目太瘋
男到這就是愛情 這不錯
甲組的 好不好
0050那一次以為哲哲是瘋子
其實是被股市耽誤的諧星
我就說過我的名言了
別人笑我太瘋癲 我笑他人看不穿
這不是我的名言
唐伯虎的名言
剪指甲 Costco才不會流血 OK
哲哲感覺心跳加快
對 沒錯
心跳加快不是戀愛的感覺
是感覺要被欺負的感覺 被嚇到
甲級分析師
來 來看一下
哲哲臉好紅
有專業
Lily傻眼 來
台指期漲百點 是不是 OK嗎
哲哲 欣興事件
本質是不是外資想上車
沒有 今天就是先洗一下籌碼
這跟外資沒有關係
哲哲覺得美伊要和談了嗎
有嗎 有這個新聞嗎
應該沒有這個新聞吧
為什麼要問這個
目前為止沒有
哲哲額頭流汗了
真的我流汗了 擦一下
可以讓我緊張的人事物已經不多了
很簡單 要嘛就適應它
要嘛就解決它
我決定解決導播
你可以不用來了 明天休息一天
開玩笑的 來
今天國巨狂買
明天國巨還會跌嗎
0050什麼時候加碼
0050 你們拜託認真看我的節目
我最討厭就是那種不看我的節目
或者只看60秒在這邊嫌的
沒關係 你現在可能是新粉絲
0050那是我叔叔有練過
0050正確的觀念是
Anywhere Anytime
閉著眼睛 任何時刻就買
因為你不會像我一樣抓轉折
等你像我這樣抓轉折
回檔10% 20%的時候
對 下次回檔20%可能什麼時候
不知道
可能是從6萬點殺到5萬點 是
6萬多點殺到5萬點
那6萬點殺到5萬點
是不是還是比現在
我買的4萬點還高 是
那你不如就現在就買
懂我的意思嗎
你等到那個時候 回檔的時候
你買的可能還是比現在的台股貴
那為什麼不現在買
這是有研究的
我的福利社也拍了好幾集這個
沒有人像我這樣子的
我當一個分析師
我賣個幾萬本
賺多少錢而已
賺幾十萬而已
這是真的啦
這個很難賺你知道嗎
跟我買個ETF
一下子一天多就賺1000萬差很多
為什麼
因為我要以正視聽
就是任何時間買就可以
而且我要告訴大家觀念
把它當作存豬公
存豬公什麼意思
需要錢的時候再宰
那不是全部宰來吃
不是全部宰來拿錢
比如說你存到1000萬
好不容易存到1000萬
我現在臨時出大事了怎麼辦
臨時出大事怎麼辦
拿一點錢
住院需要100萬就拿100萬
沒關係
你那時候可能是從1 200萬存的
怎麼樣都快
今天還有個新聞
有個主播
我在哪邊 日本還是泰國
還是英國
那飛機不是旅遊不便險嗎
結果等了3個小時多
不好意思 要滿4個小時
我就說有些壽險的
我要強調 跟壽險業沒有關係
保險公司本質上你好像在怎麼樣
法律教學
你懂我意思嗎 是
你要知道什麼事符合
你怎麼知道
他要問你
你現在已經3小時50分了
你要說再等10分鐘我再登機嗎
不行啊
你這樣聽得懂嗎
沒有滿4個小時就沒有旅遊不便險
就沒有旅遊不便險的那個
所以真的保險保應該保的就好
保這些壽險 保給家人受益
這樣就可以了
其他的不用保了
你們相信我賺到錢了
你怎麼會賺到錢
都嘛壽險公司在賺到錢
你是這一次賺啊
某種方面你也是在賭啊 你懂不懂
你們這一群人裡面
有人賺到錢 有人賠錢
最後是我專家賺錢
我雖然這樣講很不專業
我覺得我這樣講會得罪人家
但是我真的希望你聽得懂啊
可以買保險
我也是希望
因為大家也希望大家有飯吃
保險業務員有飯吃
但是你不用期待太多
買基本的就很好了
我知道這樣會得罪人
但是我講的都是
這是我講的 我的看法
這是我個人的看法
剛才那段比較有爭議啦
用賭這一段
只是我要告訴你
你看光這個保險或什麼
癌症啊 怎麼樣啊
根本就很麻煩
高資產客戶資金大洗牌
存款創4年低點有沒有看到
大家存款有沒有看到
現在大家都知道
傻瓜才把錢放在銀行
存款從50%到40%
那這些錢跑到哪邊
會買房地產嗎
要嘛就買房子嘛
要嘛就買股票嘛 是
當然是股票
所以股票難怪殺不下來
大戶都在進場 是不是
基金有沒有看到 17%有沒有看到
17%很多有沒有看到
史上新高有沒有看到 有
基金分四路流有沒有看到
存款減少了 基金增加了
債券增加了 保險增加了
我還是要告訴你
基金是最高的 我不建議
保險可以降低一點點 好不好
我覺得可以降低一點點
當然我不要再得罪人了 不好意思
保險業務會員我還是愛你們好不好
我一下得罪銀行
一下得罪保險 一下得罪老師
我講話都很實在 你們不要生氣
尤其是真的很多人會被取代
我是為你們好 好不好 OK嗎
保險能賺到錢其實不是好的事
對啊 你們幹嘛管那些
什麼旅遊不便險 什麼癌症險
你們為什麼不花錢去做健康檢查
很多癌症是可以經由健康檢查查出來的
而且都是癌症前幾名
肺炎 然後大腸癌是不是
胃癌都可以啊
大腸癌比例越來越高啊
是啊 大家那麼喜歡吃烤肉
我也喜歡吃烤肉啊
可是大腸癌你只要把腸子拉乾淨
基本上要變癌症
基本上都要3到5年
對不對 我跟你講
那都可以預防的
醫生感覺不會被取代
可是會用AI的醫生
絕對會取代不會用AI的醫生
你知道嗎
會用AI的醫生
絕對會取代不會用AI的醫生
記得我這句話
比如說你現在有感冒
有時候感冒有些是怎樣
有些感冒可能是需要截肢的
有些感冒陪著身體的腫脹
那可能不同的情況你知道嗎
我的意思是說你只有感冒
你很多症狀有時候問醫生
你不如先問AI
台灣最奇怪的是
你還不知道要看哪一科
你問AI也可以 對
所以你們花點錢
我跟你講
如果你們現在兩個軟體要選一個
ChatGPT跟Gemini
鄭重推薦ChatGPT
以前說在Gemini面前
ChatGPT是垃圾
現在要換過來
在ChatGPT面前
Gemini是垃圾 OK嗎
近境跟夏筠婷裝修爭議嗎
這個我不知道
你們真的 好不好 還有什麼
說實話總會被討厭
華新科OK啦
來 這是什麼東西
這亂寫話的我看不懂
哲哲有個愛情投資絕學
沒有這個事
哲哲只是喜歡講幹話而已 好不好
來 還有什麼東西
來啦 如果今天老投顧怎麼樣
3374精材
你不覺得精材很變態嗎
我是不是說大戶裡面在洗 有沒有看到
那一天跌停板
我不是說在洗 有沒有看到 是
你看大戶很狠
明天要不要追 明天不要追
我跟你講啦
明天再一根
漲停對不對 是
不要漲停就好 漲7%以上
那我告訴你
基本上可能要600元見
真的嗎
甚至有可能1000元
你知道嗎
這麼厲害 我覺得大戶就是
先不要1000元 至少800元
我講的是可能
我是分析師 投資沒有一定
我精材已經等很久了
這看起來就是要拉的啦
你看喔 精材很恐怖
它就是一直磨我 洗我
你看那時候252不是跟國巨一樣嗎 對
是不是 不殺下去怎麼買
你看252到現在422了
你自己看252到422.5
422.5除以252
漲快70% 厲不厲害 厲害
從這邊啦
漲67%
可是我們賺更多 來看一下
看一下 恭喜喔
精彩 精彩 精彩
真的很精彩 我的股票真的很精彩
好不好 你看我每天做很多AI圖也是一樣
等一下喔 來
你看欣興 我買100多塊
去年的事而已
去年 前年的事而已
精材今天又拉漲停了有沒有看到
昨天拉漲停 今天又拉漲停有沒有看到
8月份最後一天
幫我念一下 來
8月31號星期一下午1點37分
恭喜3374精材股價一度衝上漲停
創下歷史新高
我們買進到現在最高已經大賺118%
我持續看好它 手上持股獲利續抱
恭喜大家賺大錢啦
你都買到了嗎
精材賺118%
這跟環球晶一樣
環球晶好像本來賺170%還是180%
還是200%
我印象中賺超過170%我還沒走
拜託你要賺小錢
請你不要參加我的會員
我就是要賺大的
我很少賺5% 10%就走了
這個實在是瞧不起我
為什麼 就像我講的
你現在買個台灣50
你一年都可以平均績效20%
我是要賺大的
人不要看那麼短 你懂不懂
有時候看那麼短沒有意義 你懂嗎
真的 我是要賺大的
我不會說一定
但是我就是會努力去做
這就是我的個性好不好
人在做天在看
好不好 你看精材 自己看是不是
今天我在Threads上面就寫了
蠻搞笑的
我寫什麼 看一下
這邊 有沒有
買進國巨 悲喜加劇
記得 我Threads就這個帳號
不會Threads截圖
叫你加什麼LINE或社群
沒有這一回事
我不會主動叫你加LINE的啦
除了我的節目最後收尾的時候
說你要不要加而已啊
我不會在軟體上面 Threads上面
叫你加好不好 那都假的啦
我不需要在Threads上面
主動叫你加啦
你要不要加隨便你啦 懂不懂
買進國巨 悲喜加劇
你知道這個裡面
至少有快30個假帳號
這是真的帳號啦
有藍勾勾看一下好不好 藍勾勾
買進國巨 悲喜加劇
不是漲停就是跌停
那下面就有人留言說
哲哲你的環球晶呢
我說那為什麼我不講精材 莫名其妙
什麼話題熱 我想講什麼就講什麼
但是我跟你講
各位網友都是一樣
我想刪留言就刪留言 我想封鎖就封鎖
OK嗎
這是我的人生自由 OK嗎
不喜歡可以退出我的頻道
或跟我對做沒有關係
如果你真的想跟我對做
代表的是你連一個人
是不是贏家都看不出來
你可以退出股市了
我是認真跟你講的
如果你每一檔股票都跟我對做
基本上我認為你不是股市贏家
因為你連股市贏家
或者這個人至少在股市中有一點能力的
你都看不出來 退出股市
我跟你講真的退出股市 好不好
OK嗎 我是說真的
我真的歡迎跟我對做啦
反正你跟我對做
你不用現在退出股市
你跟我對做 你應該就會退出股市
我績效這麼好 你還要跟我對做
我們看一下南亞科最後殺起來
這一段可能MSCI會買進
然後又有投信 外資買進
這一段又殺下去 就這樣子而已
你這個對於今天尾盤1點過後的
我以前靠MSCI
以前好像中美晶很多股票
太陽能或聯發科
或是說列入MSCI新增成分股
都至少會漲2根漲停板
我靠那個賺很多錢
不只賺什麼幾百萬什麼的
可是那已經是20年前的事情
所以我現在跟你講 現在沒有用了
以前資訊不對稱很好做
而且合法
我這一段應該有人有印象啦
以前那個做研究MSCI很好賺錢
所以什麼時候做什麼事情
哲哲很厲害好不好
來 我們來看一下
6919康霈
康霈這只是中實戶 大戶要不要
一場空啊 我覺得這個
我希望真的是0050要改變機制
沒有營收 或者根本就沒什麼賺錢
或者是上市沒有連續幾年賺錢
不要列入0050好不好
雖然這個對0050來講是小錢啦
1兆以上是小錢
但是我真的覺得
這個籌碼都是中實戶 大戶養的
要不要去拉而已
但是我講多了 我變成得罪別人
不想講了
裡面很多台灣很有名的中實戶
就我的個性只是講實話
但是我沒有想要去攻擊別人
制度要改啦 好不好
康霈離開0050就好了
來 我們來跟你講
因為0050是大家的錢嘛
來 然後還有什麼
所以今天為什麼 哲哲為什麼
不用為什麼 我跟你講
2327國巨
就像我講環球晶大家覺得
環球晶還不是拉起來了 我都不懂耶
你們為什麼不爭取1000元的日子
今天還看到跌停板
最後還不是拉起來了
環球晶不是拉起來了嗎 是
華新科不是拉起來
你們跌停在那邊呼天搶地要幹什麼
就像精材前陣子跌停你要幹什麼嘛
你看我的股票
你告訴我哪一檔股票現在有比精材強
你相信我
今天開始又有很多人講精材了
到底要幹嘛
長榮前幾天又有人講
然後跌下去又沒人講
沒動又沒人講
這是老投顧啊 各位
有些根本就是在胡扯啊 各位
我們根本不去做這種事
我的股票講得很清楚啊 OK嗎
所以我剛才講到哪邊
3374精材是不是賺
賺得開心 還有什麼
微星也拉了 我說微星這個就是怎麼樣
唯一缺點漲太多 他在拉
微星這一次再突破173就漲真的喔
來 微星是什麼股票你看一下
微星是少數還沒有創新高的AI股
硬要說AI  是有扯到邊
少數沒有創新高的電子股
你看看週線圖
去年還在200多元 現在155元
為什麼我寧願買微星 買精材
精材也是一樣啊
精材前陣子股價也很低啊
也是2萬多點的精材啊
是最近還拉起來啊
微星也是一樣2萬多點的股票啊
為什麼都選2萬多點的股票
因為我現在台灣股市
4萬多快到5萬點了
我就選低基期
為什麼不買欣興
奇怪 2萬多點的欣興是90幾塊
70幾塊我被人家罵得要死
這樣懂嗎 我寧願你先不要受傷
先求不傷身再求療效
好不好 不要融資
被動元件不要融資 持股不要超過7成
最好是3到4成就不錯了 好不好
這樣已經很集中了啦
你看人家 還幫你算一下欣興跌停板
主動型ETF這些股票
大部分都不會超過10%以上 是不是
所以你看這都是邏輯
我都教得很清楚 好不好
還是要分散一點點 好不好
股市懦夫的救星
萬綠叢中一點紅的精材
太扯了 噴很大 對啊
哲哲已經放棄好學生技嘉
不會啊 微星跟技嘉有機會一起漲
好不好 OK
投資長好強 謝謝大家 是不是
我跟你講
如果我是那種
每天跟你講要收會員的老師
每天要賺大錢
每天跟你講漲停板的老師
你看講越多漲停板
越不敢參加選股比賽 你知道嗎
我講的是真的
外面投顧有些真的很誇張
我還是要強調
我講的不是單一分析
我講的是一個現象
那你去看一件事情
如果我是那種老師
每天講漲停板
我跟你講精材我是有的
而且我也是講很久
這半年基本上我常常在講
我講應該有超過100次以上
應該有吧 導播怎麼可能沒有
100次一定有啦
好不好 講精材至少超過100次
原則上應該是有 來
我講精材超過100次
那你看如果我是要收會員
我是不是今天從頭到尾要講這一段
你看這一段就漲了多少
67% 剛才說67%
不要算這一段 算這4天就好
這4天大概從280到422
422除以287 47%
光是一個禮拜就47%扯不扯 太強了
一個禮拜就47% 是
我可以講1小時
不是啊 要不要參加會員隨便你
國巨又關我什麼事情
國巨我成本頂多在附近
我還有一些400多元的 是不是
我不懂有什麼好煩的 是不是 沒錯
我不懂 400多元
講的好像國巨是我的問題
跟我沒關係啊
你們1200元殺下去
是那些很多分析師 很多外資看好的
跟我沒關係
我從頭到尾告訴你們風險
我幹嘛講國巨
因為你們看到跌停板
你就覺得哲哲好遜
不對 我成本又不是那麼高 是不是
我幹嘛花個20分鐘
花個10分鐘講國巨
然後花個10分鐘講環球晶
影響我收會員
I don't care
你要不要參加會員隨便你
你看不出來我是贏家 我不在乎
我講個30分鐘的精材就可以了
有什麼好講的
你都說哲哲沒有基本面 沒有什麼
哲哲沒有講基本面
你要講基本面 我還怕你聽不懂
我怎麼會沒講 是不是
你看你那天直接考我
我說至少先大跌再說 對
講個欣興都是一樣
那時候根本就沒消息
助理給我的新聞也是一半一半
也沒有跟我講什麼洗產地這個東西 是
是沒講洗產地還是沒講什麼
他沒講得很清楚
我資訊不足我還是給你判斷
有誰能像我這樣子嗎
要講基本面我比他們厲害
比很多人厲害
光是一個聯發科講1萬塊
我就噹爆了
是不是 麥格理
我說你用後年EPS
現在聯發科為什麼拉不起來
因為TPU晶片可能會被人家搶單 對
在算什麼TPU晶片
TPU晶片被搶單你怎麼說1萬塊
你現在為了要拉到1萬塊
是把後年的EPS算進去
然後再把後年的本益比算進去
EPS你調高 本益比也調高
你在說什麼瘋話
Take a shower
冷靜一下比較實在
這個也是一個梗
Take a shower
還滿好笑的 因為你英文不錯
沒有想到可以這樣
說瘋話 Take a shower
諧音梗
來 英台語諧音梗
真的有講精材 講了啦
鴻海 這些股票都是一樣
鴻海你慢那就換
我也覺得我也想換
說老實話我也想換
我有叫一些 不能講那麼清楚
成本高的你就先等著
如果成本附近的
我覺得你可以考慮換 好不好
沒關係嘛 我們不是
鴻海我們不是全部重壓
我最不喜歡的是
不是會員不要來抱怨
不是會員不要問我什麼時候買 價格買
這個絕對不可能跟你講
我講了我混什麼
是不是 好不好 OK
智原要磨多久
要磨一段時間
因為智原不算真正的AI
就不算真正切入
它是算側邊切入 好不好 OK嗎
哲哲寶貝力積電怎麼辦
我就說了沒有黃董我覺得很無聊
想聽聽看寶雅
寶雅現在不知道擴張
好像幾十個店面嗎
還是上百個店面
不看好啦 雖然女生很喜歡好不好
我覺得網路還是比較實在
環球晶怎麼看
1000元以下就買啦
富世達能買嗎 都拉起來了
今天精材 國巨
華新科 精材 你賺翻了
世界 微星
微星我看起來
微星準備要噴出去了
世界有沒有救
世界就是牛皮 怎麼會沒救
牛皮怎麼會沒救
世界也是 你看 你記得一件事
現在不是很多股票對不對 對
我們看一下 現在很多股票
台灣股市不會回到4萬點
但是有些股票要死不活
你懂我的意思嗎
來 我給你看
你看這樣殺下去對不對 對
它反彈對不對 它彈得很短
它離底部近不近 很近
還滿近的
像這種離底部近的股票對不對
像精材拉到這邊來對不對 是
離底部近的股票
其實你要開心還能買
還有週年慶 你要買
國巨也是一樣離底部很近
你看精材就離底部不近
殺下去有沒有看到 直接V轉
所以你看到它沒有彈起來的時候
殺下去的時候你就要買
這邊買更漂亮
這邊買最漂亮
應該這樣講 這邊買是行家中的行家
這邊買是技術分析的行家 是
這是真正的贏家
這是行家
贏家就是我
不好意思 我的台灣50不是買在這邊嗎
我是贏家
這邊是行家 技術派
這邊打底 沿著什麼
沿著季線而上 這是季線對不對 對
季線看起來沒有要破了
這邊買 超漂亮
這邊買是行家
我這邊買是贏家
都可以啊
可是不是上去再買
所以我覺得世界先進跟環球晶都是一樣
打第二隻腳
而且第二隻腳都很弱 看起來要破底
不會 年底破什麼底
我就跟你講
連MIT都說 老師都被取代了
再講一次我的預告
基本上你現在智商
只要正常能120
120是優異的啦
智商你只要110以上
120就算資優
110以上或甚至100以上
就是智力中等以上
基本上你現在不用上學了
你直接所有的課程直接用AI
解釋的比你們補習班老師還好
解釋的比你們學校老師還好
我講的是事實 不好意思
我不是要不尊重老師
我很尊師重道
我是那一種 我跟你講
我最不喜歡的男生或女生
就是有那個
現在比較少坐了
因為我現在太紅了
有人看到我都尖叫 你知道
我的壓力好大
我是那種坐捷運 我看到對方
就是說坐那個博愛座 是
博愛座那種 年輕人坐博愛座
我是那種很不喜歡那一種
就是他不會是我的朋友
你知道那種人
我是那一種人
就是我沒有講你們誰
就是明明有空位
你偏偏要坐博愛座的年輕人
我不喜歡
如果是說你身體不舒服
你只剩博愛座我可以接受
就是那種
莫名其妙一定要坐博愛座的年輕人
我是不喜歡的
我覺得我比較道德感
不要這樣講 就是
所以我是很尊師重道的人
可是我要告訴大家就是
沒辦法 以後補教行業
很多行業要被取代
就是因為AI
可是很多人被取代
代表有很多商機
很多商機你知道嗎 OK嗎
你要記得我講這些東西 來
這邊買贏家 那邊買行家 上面買敗家
不錯
新日興 來看一下
新日興是我的強項
3374新日興
今天又拉了
不是 新日興沒有
看錯 新日興代碼多少 忘記了
3376是不是 沒有漲
新日興可以做 摺疊手機OK
因為我都想買了 好不好
到時候我會買摺疊手機跟新的手機
各買一支
因為我現在比較習慣Face ID好不好
因為比較安全 好不好
這個跟大家講 來
分析師會不會被AI取代 當然不會
AI現在最大的問題是
即時性的問題他會有問題
因為它都是用過去的資料
所以為什麼我說老師比較危險
因為你那些數學
過個10年 20年也不會有變 對
英文也不會有變 那沒有辦法
你知道嗎 OK嗎
我媽媽今天早上還給我看
你看AI短劇 你看我都看得很開心
我看得他是很粗糙 他看得很開心
我怕再過一年後
那種很精美怎麼辦
這個跟大家講 來
所以哲哲推薦大立光嗎 宜鼎
我不理你們 一堆股票不是我的
今天直播人數8000多人
國巨 環球晶不行你來找我
那你怎麼不想想看
你看我在Threads的時候
還在拉起來
那時候聽到
你現在是不是尾盤可以拉起來
就不要明天給我拉起來
3374精材
我認為明天有機會漲一根
我不敢說 因為漲那麼多
但是如果明天
中實戶 大戶還可以再拉一根
我剛才說7%
那我告訴你
有可能真的是700元 800元見
哲哲不論對或錯一切的一切預告在前面
現在幾分了
51 好 要結束了
所以你看精材這個東西OK嗎
還有微星你看一下
大家說微星怎麼樣
微星也是一樣
看一下微星賺30%
大漲快7% 2377微星
你看我到現在才秀簡訊
所以要不要參加會員
你自己考慮好不好 我不勉強
反正很多人參加
有看到了嗎
微星 有沒有看到
星星之火足以燎原
我那時候是不是說星星之火
你們猜到欣興去
不是 是微星
我的股票多強 這種行情多強
拉回去的股票更開心
不論對或錯哲哲一切的一切預告在前面
歡迎來電洽詢0800668085
或者加我的LINE私訊我
說哲哲我要賺大錢
你也可以詢問我會費
我答應你
我竭盡所能來幫你賺大錢
謝謝各位